voyez bien qu'il manque eric naulleau
eric naulleau hier qu est ce qu on lui
avait dit vous l'avez dit qu'on voulait
olivier obame alors doit donner d'autres
marques
bien entendu si évidemment je peux
toucher bougez-vous pierre sarrade
rachiki à 10 h m
machichi à biberist exactement 10 h m
djoko poels exacte entre la coque et
pourrait bien sûr pour les chaussures
les cherry hill et là eric naulleau est
très difficile et il m'a décidée et vous
allez voir ce que vous allez voir s'il
vous plaît nagy mais c'est le tapis
rouge
alors je sais pas d'où il va arriver il
va arriver de quelque part eric naulleau
je ne sais pas d'où je venais d'arriver
alors ses toiles et on me dit on me dit
qu'il va arriver de derrière cette porte
défilé de mannequins eric naulleau on
adore c'est pas là on est on a passé un
style à la musique gueule entendu ces
partis chez vous dîtes nous ce qu'on
sait
mais bon
[Applaudissements]
et alors
le jeu
[Applaudissements]
non mais
mais l'échangé et c'est changer bien des
frères et sentons plus qu'avant soit là
mais regardez non mais la vérité c'est
que yahia alors clamé lors la balme un
même élan la batterie c'est un truc qui
me fait les meufs les matches comme ça
eric sur la tête de ma mère tu es non
mais c'est espèce me voir je vais
m'occuper de toi alors comme les alliés
cinq ans bien sûr comme quoi les
aménagistes rien sinon regardez regardez
salalah
après sony c'est très simple c'est sûr
et c'est ça qui lui va bien merci et
bravo en tout cas et al thani c'est un
parapluie dans ton slip